Let's begin with network communications.
Obviously, if you have a distributed application the pieces of
the application have to be connected together over some kind of network.
Some of the issues that arise in dealing with applications that
are split across a network are how are errors handled.
And there a variety of different kinds of errors that might arise.
There are synchronous errors.
That is, when a particular request is made, and
part of a system awaits a response.
Or asynchronous errors.
That is spontaneous issuing of some kind of
notification that the rest of the system has to respond to.
Primary concern here is reliable delivery of these messages,
particularly the error messages.
If the network itself is unreliable, various strategies such as delivering more
than once can be employed, but then again, you don't want to have more than one
actual copy of a message received and, and acted upon.
And communicating across the network,
another issue relates to how the data is represented.
It may well be the case,
because we're in a heterogeneous situation, that the different machine and
the different machines represent data in different ways.
And then third is the whole question of transaction.
If there's a database involved, it may well be the case
that of the multiple users which might be using the application, one user
is updating the database at the same time another user is reading the database.
And there's the potential for the receipt of information that is not up
to date with respect to the, the database.